hello everyone I hope you're still
having a great Sunday and since you
enjoyed that little skirmish between me
rasheeda's Medina and Tigran Petrosian I
thought I'd show you a game between
Michael and Paul Karras also kind of a
clash of styles and this is actually
their first encounter this is the first
time two of them ever played the the
game was played in 1954 I was a team
game a team match between Estonia and
Latvia and of course an onboard one
there was the magician of Riga Michael
Thailand on board one for Estonia was
the Estonian powerhouse Paul Paul Karras
and it's quite an interesting game a lot
of poison to it and again we'll see a
very interesting clash of styles so so
let's see this game tall has the white
pieces and he opens with d4 Knight to f6
we have c4 and c6
Karras goes for the Kings Indian defense
Knight to c3 Bishop to g7 efore d6 this
is the standard line and Knight to f3
we have castles Bishop to e2 b 5 and we
have Bishop to e3 this is the gligar 8
system so Knight to c6 d5 Knight to e7
and we have h3 Harris plays Knight to d7
announcing that he's about to push f5 so
top plays Knight to d2 making making
some space here on DF file so he can
push his own born after Karras pushes at
5 we had at 5 f3 and here you can either
push put upon to f4 maybe cause the
position you can also capture on e4 you
can ignore this completely and play
something like b6 continue developing
Kara's goes for F captures on e4 we have
Knight captures on e4 and here Knight to
f5 and this is an excellent square for
the knight it's not gonna be easy to
kill you this night away from f5 of
course you can always push g4 but then
you're kind of weakening the King side
so no reason to do this just yet Bishop
to g5 now attacking Karis queen on the
8th and 9th to f6
we have Bishop to d3 and Queen to e8
unpinning and now this night is
definitely ready to capture this knight
on e4 and then this Knight is ready to
jump to g3 so we have knife to e2 by tau
now this Knight is guarding the g3
square so after Kerris captures this
night this night will still be
protecting the g3 square Knight captures
we have Bishop captures and Bishop to f6
now Bishop captures rook captures and
Queen to d2 so so far it's a pretty
equal game by both of them both players
controlling some some important squares
and here Karis plays c5 so definitely a
good move trying to close the center and
preventing tal from pushing b4 but tell
doesn't like this here at our place B
captures on c6 we have B captures on c6
and g4 now finally kicking that night as
you just really no way to get rid of it
unless you want to capture with the
bishop
but then this bishop then this bishop
comes to a5 and again it's it's a very
nice square for Carausius pieces so g4
we have Knight to e7
and now tall castles maybe this castling
move was a bit premature as as you can
see talk can also Castle queenside so
maybe maybe improving the position first
before deciding which way to go but okay
tah goes King side castle because he
wants to attack so King safety comes
first Bishop to e6 now attacking the c4
pawn we have B 3 and here Karis pushes
d5 and this is a very important move in
the game it all has to figure out what
he wants to do here it doesn't want to
capture on d5
does he want to move the bishop let's
see what happens if he captures on d5 if
he kept her son d5 then comes this Queen
to d7 move pinning the pawn as the queen
of d2 is undefended and here the best
move for towel would be rook to f2
preparing in Knight to f3 Knight to c3
and then the rook will be defending the
Queen on b2 so after black recaptures
here now simply Knight to c3 and the
pawn on d5 is now attacked three times
you can't capture the bishop because
Carausius queen is also undefended
be seven so rook to d8 rook to d1 and
after rook to d6 now the bishop can be
captured so Bishop to d3 Bishop captures
Queen captures and at the end of this
little skirmish okay maybe a six
preventing white knight from jumping to
b5 but India and the material will be
completely equal and the curse will have
these two strong central pawns now which
side is better here probably black is a
little better but one important thing is
that Karis is controlling all four
important central squares and there's an
old thing in chess he he who controls
the center will eventually win the game
so tall doesn't like this after d5 top
plays Queen to g5 now going after Karis
is undefended rook on f6 we have Queen
to f7 defending and now Bishop to d3
here towel offers the pawn well he
doesn't offer it immediately but it will
be a very weak pawn D captures on c4 we
have Bishop captures Bishop captures and
now B captures on c4 and as you can see
this is a very weak pawn
still carries can't capture because the
rook will still be undefended on f6 but
here caris plays rook a to the f8 now he
has this triple battery on the F file
the f3 point is very weak as style
decided to push that g4 pawn just to get
rid of the knight so although you can
see that the g4 move was useful at the
time tile plated and now it it really
looks like a big big weakness so going
to e5 capturing a pawn so for now
tallies up the pawn but this doesn't
really mean anything
and one reason okay I mean you really
don't have a better move than to capture
this pawn but one reason probably why L
did it is because he was maybe
considering Karis will capture on f3 if
Karis captures on f3 then Karis
basically is agreeing to a draw because
after rook captures and Queen captures
talking captured the night and now Cara
says this Queen - f - check and it's a
draw by repetition King gauge one queen
of three and the Queen can simply
continue checking the White King so
after this Queen to e5 move Karis is not
interested in a draw rather he played
rook to e6 attacking Dallas Queen and
also there's an undefended not
undefended night behind the Queen so
here it also has an option does he go
queen bee too because the night has to
be defended or does he go Queen to h2 if
he goes Queen to b2 which was also an
option then after rook to e3 again
attacking the f3 pawn now three times
and also the queen is now attacking the
c4 pawn Knight to g3 rook captures and
now Queen to e5 and now what do you play
here if you capture then rook captures
and the knight and g3 is defending the
rook so Queen to g2 coin 25 is actually
a pretty good move for defending the
knight and g3 also harassing that night
and e7 so probably after Queen to f4
Queen captures rook captures rook after
stroke captures and King to g2 now you
don't go for the c4 pawn rather there's
an even better move rook to a3 kind of
paralyzing tall's move on a1 you can't
move it you can't even move it with
tempo and you want to go for the night
because rook captures and a2 comes with
check so it would be kind of an equal
material but it would be it would be a
better position for black and in carries
his hands probably a winning position so
that's probably the reason why after
this rook to e6 tile decided not to go
for Luke to be chose he decided to go
for Luke to h2 Queen to h2 this keeps
the material on the board and leaves
some chances rook to e3 again going for
the f3 pawn also attacking the c4 pawn
we have night to g3 now and Queen
captures on c4 so here Karis wins back
at the pawn we have nice to e4 and now
comes Queen to d4 as you see the Queen
is now lined up with the king the thread
is rook captures knight on e4 this will
come with check so rook a to d1
attacking the Queen and now comes Rock
to d3 check opening up a discovered
attack and here top plays Knight to f2
attacking the rook and III also adding
more protection to the rock on
and here we have rook eight captures on
f3 Kara's grabs another pawn we have
rook captures rook captures and the
knight of course can capture the knight
is pinned and here we have Queen to b8
check by tal King to g7 and now between
to c7 attacking the knight here although
probably a better move was rook to e1 as
this does activate the rook also with a
temple but for some reason tall decided
to go for a queen to c7 we have went to
e3 defending now the queen is defending
the knight the queen is defending the a
7-point the night from e7 is defending
the c6 pawn so everything is defended in
Karis camp Queen to b7 we have king to
h6 not allowing the King to stay pinned
another Knight can move and here Queen
to be won by towel rook to d2 we have
Queen to b3 offering an exchange of
Queens and this is a very interesting
moment in the game as well why does it
all offer a trade of Queens here
well there really isn't a better move I
mean you don't really have any any other
choices but to go for a trade of Queens
and as this pawn is very weak probably
Karis will have at least one point
advantage in the endgame but they are
isolated pawns isolated a pawn isolated
C pawn so maybe tall could pick it up
with the rook and the night it's hard to
say but here went out played Queen to b3
this Queen to b3 is an extremely
poisonous move very very sneaky idea by
tau and this is what fell had in mind
Stella had in mind that if Queen
captures then pawn captures on b3 from
b3 this pawn will be stopping Harris's a
pawn and carries a C pawn as well and
this is what L had in mind if Karis
tried to go for the pawn rook to be 2
then comes Knight to e4 and if you
capture it then comes rook to f7 and
caris loses a piece there's there's no
way to defend it if you if you move the
knight let's say Knight to d5 you get g5
King h5 and the rock captures I'm h7
checkmate so a lot of poison to
going to be three move so Karis isn't
interested in this Karis plays Knight to
d5 he says okay I'm down with the Queen
trade but we will we'll trade on e3 not
on b3 and here again capturing the Queen
probably would give tall some chances
because there's really not a better move
here but towel isn't interested in this
towel pushes g5 and g5 is again okay you
can't capture it with the King obviously
if you capture it with the king then you
lose the game Queen captures Queen
Knight captures and then comes Knight to
e4 check and picking up the rook King h5
Knight captures and Knight captures on
f1 team captures and tallies up a piece
probably winning this game the king is
close to this pawn maybe not a knight
will probably be able to pick up the a
pawn and then this one will be promoted
most likely but after this g5 move Karis
played King to h5 Queen - Queen after
Sun g5 is also possible but Karis
although he probably could have
calculated this he doesn't want to give
tall any breathing room for example
after Queen captures you have to see
that after 94 check King g4 packing it
for King h5 and Queen to f3 threatening
discoveries you actually can't play King
to h4 and here doll
really doesn't have anything it's it's
perfectly fine position for black
winning winning winning position so
after this g5 move check Karis decided
to play King to h5 so not not giving
tall anything
quita b7 tall now is threatening Queen
captures on h7 with check Queen to g3
check King h1 and rook captures night so
Karis wins apiece but he allows this
Queen captures on h7 so top plays it
Queen characters on h7 team to g5 and
here we have h4 of course you can
capture on h4 if you capture then Queen
captures King captures and rook captures
rook now
it's it's rook against a rook and pawn
against the night and three points
better position for white if that could
win it it's hard to say but definitely
after age four
Karis cannot capture it so he played the
team to f6 and it was in this position
that Michael tile resigned the game why
did he resign well he's down a piece
he's down a pawn and there's really
nothing for him to to try here he can
try some checks but he saw that black
will finally black will actually find a
sanctuary on a6 for example let's see
some Queen h8 check ideas King goes
three seven Queen g7 check King goes 3
eights now Quinn back to h8 check King
goes not to d7 we have Queen to g7 check
King c8 now Queen to h8 check King Tubby
7 and here if you play Queen to g7 then
King to a6 and there are no more checks
and if you try some rugby one idea rugby
one check then again night simply covers
up queen h7 check King goes to a6 and
there are no more checks in the position
and there is no defense against Queen 2
H 2 and this will be checkmate so yeah
after King to have sextile resigned the
game and the first encounter between
these two went to the Estonian Paul
Karras so yeah I mean so it's a pretty
cool game I do hope you enjoyed it
Thailand Karis played a lot of games
together I think they're there
all-in-all score is 8 wins for Karis 5
wins for Thailand 17 draws and there is
my favourite game between towel and
Karis actually ended in a draw but it's
such a magical draw town manages to pull
it off it's a completely lost position
but Tom manages the trick Karis and like
sacrifices three pieces for a draw I
will try to find that game is so I think
it's actually my favourite draw but yeah
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
I would like to thank Marco you super
Malik most Fi and Nick Davis for a
contribution to my channel thanks a lot
to really appreciate it thank you for
watching and I will see you soon and of
course
you can always check to my previous
videos here forgot about that I don't
know what's with me today sorry
yeah I think oh for watching and I will
see you soon